هو العقل المدبر لاعمال سينمائيه تاريخيه
وافضل ما قدمته السينما العالميه تايتنك
وافاتار تجربه بدات منذ نحو 45 عاما عندما
كان جيمس كاميرون ابن الرابعه والعشرين
ويخرج اول افلام فيلم خيال علمي قصير تبلغ
مدته اثنتين 10 دقيقه بميزانيه 20,000
دولار حصل عليها من طبيب اسنان واحداث
صورها في غرفه معيشه فوضى مكتمله الاركان
لكنها سجلت ولاده اسطوره ههه
وخلال الاسبوع نجح كاميرا في كسر ارقامه
القياسيه بنفسه نجاح فيلم افاتار ذا واي
وفوتر في كسر حاجز المليارات دولار في
ارادات شباك تذاكر العالمي افاتار الثاني
في المركز السادس ضمن الافلام الاكثر
تحقيقا للايرادات في التاريخ
الاخرين الجزء الاول من افاتار تايتانيك
[موسيقى]
ذات يوم يجلس الشاب الكندي جيمس كاميرون
في صاله السينما يشاهد الجزء الاول من
سلسله افلام
ينتهي الفيلم
في اول
الثمانيناتير الذي صدر عام 1984
الجزء الاول كاملا داخل سيارته وبالمناسبه
مع حقوقه بدولار واحد مقابل ان يخرج
الفيلم بنفسه
مليار دولار لم يكن الفيلم الوحيد الذي
يشاهده كاميرون اثناء النوم
في طفولته وكتب نصه عام 95 قبل 14 عاما
قرر كاميرا لانتظار حتى تتقدم تكنولوجيا
ويخرج ويخرج الفيلم للنور كما اراده في
مخيلته وهو الحال نفسه بالنسبه للجزء
الثاني الذي صدر في ديسمبر الماضي كذلك لم
ياتي لكاميرا في احلامه لكنه قال انه نفذه
فقط لتمويل حلمه في استكشاف في البحار
واستخدم الفيلم ذريعه لاستكشاف في حطام
السفينه المنكوبه في قاع المحيط في 2012
كسر رقما قياسيا خارج السينما حيث اصبح
اول من يصل منفردا لاعمق بقعه في محيطي
كوكب الارض المخرج الذي نالت افلامه اثنين
واربعين ترشيحا في مسابقات الاوسكار اليوم
اولوياته هي افاتار ربما لنهايه مسيرته هي
مهمته التي ضحعها لاجلها بثلاثه عشر عاما
دون ان يخرج شيئا لكنه طور خلالها اربعه
اجزاء متتاليه من هذه السلسله انها تصوير
جزئين منها من ضمنها الجزء الثاني الذي
يعرض حاليا في دور العرض اما اخر الاجزاء
فيعرض عام
ثاني و20
[موسيقى]